COLIN GODWIN: This
class has shaped
how I approach communicating
with others in showing me
how differently languages
that I previously
understood to be
invalid, including
Creole, Southern American
English after I hear anything,
I'm like--
Stereotypical
languages like that
are actually very
systematic, and should
be regarded as languages
in and of themselves that
should be given
validity inside the US,
whether that be through court
room interpreters for people
like Rachel Jeantel, who spoke
primarily African-American
English, or even just inside
of Haiti teaching classes
in Creole, as a means to
connect with students better.
ELENA ALBERTI: Yeah.
Also I think how this class
shaped my communication
is it allowed me to discuss
more difficult topics
without feeling hindered.
I didn't have to
feel like I was going
to offend anyone because it
was in the context of learning.
And I think people were very
open with answering questions
that might be seen as like,
why don't you know this,
or stuff like that.
And further, also
with the presentations
and with the essays,
I feel like you
had to develop
your communication
skills in a bunch of different
ways, not only speaking
but how we present now, and then
also how do you write an essay.
I think Dr. Nora Jackson
was really great in helping
me develop my writing style.
And yeah, I thought I was going
to say something else, but--
[LAUGHING]
LORRAINE WONG: I think
the conversations
that we had were really
interesting all the time.
Everyone has some
sort of opinion.
Some people are more willing to
speak about them than others,
and personally I feel that
oftentimes in conversations I'm
more reticent.
But this class felt
like such a safe space
that it was possible to speak
about personal experiences
or opinions on readings
and all of these things.
And I really appreciated
the presentations
that we have to do as well,
because as a communication
intensive course we have to
have some sort of oral component
and present things, and those
freak me out all the time.
But it's important to
have this type of practice
and to be able to have a safe
space in order to practice
and then be able to do it
better and better each time.
DANA VIGUE: Yeah.
And, you know, for me,
starting this summer
I'm going to be beginning
my M.D. PhD in anthropology.
And trained as an
anthropologist,
I've always had this idea
that you don't really
need interject that much
personal experience into what
you write, especially if
it's an academic work.
And from the get-go
in this class,
we were expected
to draw equal parts
from the theory with which
we engaged and equal parts
from our own
experiences and present
that in the form of a narrative,
that was in conversation
with the theory.
And I was uncomfortable
with that.
I thought that-- I had
this notion that doing so
would make my writing less
professional, less objective,
and perhaps less valuable,
because it wasn't
primarily rooted in theory.
So much of it was narrative, so
much of it was now subjective.
But I found that interrogating
my own experiences
as an academic, who's
engaging with the theory,
helped me to kind of deconstruct
stereotypes like the ones
Colin articulated, and
these preconceived notions
that we inherently
carry in when we're
trying to do objective
analyzes in a way
that I had never had the
opportunity to do before.
And so getting out
of my comfort zone
by writing these
academic papers that
were equal parts personal
narrative was something
that I think will prepare
me well as an anthropologist
to ensure that, to
a greater extent,
I'm able to understand
where I stand
in terms of a particular issue
and perhaps do more justice
when I do produce a work.
ELENA ALBERTI: And
on top of all this,
one way that I would like to
see the course improve-- which
Colin mentioned in class and
has to do with communication--
is having difficult
conversations with someone
who doesn't have your view.
Something we talked
about in this class
was that everyone here
is kind of like-minded.
We all sought out this
class for a reason.
And I think I didn't
get to challenge myself
in communicating to someone
who didn't agree with me.
And that could be a way
that educators can improve.
LORRAINE WONG: Definitely.